yeah hello welcome to our broadcast
tonight Monday sixth of June 2016 I hope
you are alright and managed to make it
to our show I'm going to start a game
pretty soonish now beyond just a matter
of seconds guys in the chat okay I'm
going to kick off and get a game started
requesting for five minutes I hope I do
quite okay um I'm not very optimistic
it's so damn hot here in my place it
really feels like my style brain is
melting anyway let's go and see what
Mickey Mouse is able to do mickey is
playing the Trump okay yeah Black Sun
says almost on time that's something we
are usually on time maybe we are like
one minute late or something not much
yeah Mickey Mouse what are you doing is
this is the most boring stuff ever again
but such as the nature of the game
sometimes if white wants to play super
solid they can do it yeah okay well this
is a this is certainly okay for black as
well maybe I can do something here with
the Queen tech a two
okay I think hmm what to do here I
wonder something would like to do
something would be five maybe let's do
this first yeah there's a suggestion I
should play the French defense in memory
of Viktor Korchnoi yeah maybe I should
should do that I was thinking if
something um if I should do something
special because of coach noise death
today um yeah at the end I decided not
to do something and to show him because
it's supposed to be a yes some
light-hearted entertainment and I think
this is okay if we still keep it like
that I think that very much every chess
side and and publication will do
something in memory of caution or also
the ICC will certainly do something so i
felt that it's probably not very
appropriate if i do something here today
for example in case of the ICC I think
it would be the most appropriate thing
if Alexia Malinsky would would do
something about coach no SS he quite
clearly knew him well from his days in
ya Leningrad it was back then so um I
think this is far more appropriate I
will certainly do something about
culture on my own channel but it's um
probably not the right place and time
here in this show
um okay so what happens here we have a
we have a pretty lame kind of position
here what's this i came i mean the the
king of porn ending is probably not that
grade IV g5 it's equal this one whom
yeah it's two equal yeah this is just
immensely boring and what to do here it
says something that I can do with it is
not so boring mmm i probably not i mean
i can try this but i keep probably will
be one rookie to win
yeah I wonder I can do this yeah Ruby
five would be interesting and now we
place interesting stuff I wants to go to
f5 some play okay okay anyway ah ok and
I'm trying to get to be porn so
something will happen in this ending
check
and there's a request for playing the
Black Lion yeah why not that that is
pretty okay i can i can do that and a
turn so what's the deal here Roxy 7 i'd
be here for rookie one it's rather draw
i think yeah that book the black line is
kind of questionable Jack I had that
stress so I'm going to get this under
under fire before maybe before a little
bit down on time
and no i haven't played magnus carlsen
recently on the ICC he has an account it
seems but I never played him with this
this new account he only played bullet
and three minute which is not my time
control ok so here I am tango be three
rupees seven Roxy form yeah yeah yeahs
internet chess clock i certainly right
here saying that cars in place often on
the ICC but usually has anonymous
accounts yep very understandable to f6
02 g6 yeah after go by instinct TM
cannot calculate this now maybe this is
wrong I don't know but it should be it
should be okay going over to g1 getting
g-form time morning rugby 6 just go back
yeah I should be a draw i guess i will
not go back check check hmm not just a
dry I just have to see that I'm not
doing something super stupid and just
prevent them and porn from going forward
check draw our third hmm
yeah this is just fini doors draw
position draw our third come on this is
a joke right I came in ok either they
actually made a mistake though shouldn't
have allowed that in the first place I
can see seven now wow yeah ok now how
stupid did I played that one and it
really unnerved me that he did Righetti
that he did that decline the drawer yeah
this is the total draw my me czechia air
okay six is much easier and still I
cannot take yeah this is losing I cannot
take one look at you seven and it's
actually tricky this is actually trick
you have to go to a 6 cm or King d8 King
date is easiest yeah now you can still
do something stupid obviously anyway oh
it's stupid yeah this is much easier
okay game started I did I give I give up
on okay because it's the cleanest way to
a draw of course everybody gives the
porn away there it's just you just
should blunder like I did so mr. Boris
here we have a we have a Dutch defense
can I do something interesting with g4
not sure how good it is let's just
develop okay yeah I need to prepare and
I need to get c4 and somehow maybe this
and then see for many books is a
question by ka um many books present
different checklists to go through
before making every move space material
development king safety do strong
players do that no they don't simply not
it's just everything forms a picture
let's aim and strong players don't do a
checklist em it kind of um it just
naturally is part of the whole
evaluation that same it's never like
okay did I look at this to look at that
that that doesn't happen okay so what
now yeah it's not a bad idea if you're
starting out with chess for sure I can
also take with this it's also very nice
for what
yeah comfortable for white the e6 being
quite weak that rook endgame still
irritates me yeah I came I mean you can
of course decline the draw you can
always do something stupid like I did mm
okay interesting we are not g5 is the
most straightforward let's do this
threatening 96
yeah that's true I never get get paired
against kingscrusher it's it's simply
because we play it entirely different
times young try phone is usually playing
in the very early morning when I
absolutely never play and he plays like
7am is an early riser and at 7am I'm
absolutely never out of bed unless
something something special is going on
I don't know Adam yeah here in this game
mr. boris and out 96 which should be
crushing black resigns okay so i've got
some points back from that silly game
before gain we're not a sinner game it's
just I just I just this happens to me if
i have a total draw in an ending i
simply stop thinking and then a blunder
stuff it just it's just very bad it
happens quite often so what do I do here
PT Capri is declining my bank oh um six
so no I try finest lot playing before
and after work he is he doesn't have I'm
clear working hours at same ah me works
on his website and does his YouTube
channel he doesn't have a an office job
quite comparable to toward what would I
ever also have flexible hours but I
usually work till later later at night
and this means i have to sleep a little
bit longer at least I need I need to
sleep
ok so here we have some some type of
Hedgehog kind of position my night is on
c6 which is a little bit uncommon ok
I'll try this maybe trade the bishop
sorry for that big bottle but I need to
constantly get some water into the
system it's so so hot iam yeah the
French defense i should i should really
do that probably caution i would be
angry i have some parts of playing the
French defense in my memory ok I was
thinking I could get this Bishop but I
cannot
hmm not my kind of position I have to
admit I really what what's the point
there i mean okay we shouldn't discuss
what what case Casey is doing but he has
his website i think this is pretty
pretty okay so five hmm yeah i miss dead
10 and chatting now he's got 94 this is
not nice I'm not a good position ok at
least I can trade a little something of
course why this better but
it's very uncomfortable this position
just goes whoop do you want I guess
pretty awful
Wow pretty pretty awful I can't list
with h4 he played something something
enterprising or I'm not sure hutch
watching me call it it's nothing it's
probably not so bad it's at least it's
not just squeezing you slowly to death
it's something weird okay I'm not saying
I'm in great shape but somehow I'm alive
maybe I didn't see that move coming then
I guess I cannot sec the Queen it's not
going to work okay I'm not sure about
this this couldn't be this could be so a
little bit interesting
I'm definitely ready to SEC the Queen if
circumstances permit and actually
threatening maybe Bishop f3 now ok so
now I could sec the queen but it's
probably not objectively working like
you have a queen move between have 7 3g
settlement ok i don't think i can sack
the Queen's Own have to do it so at
least I'm threatening something on edge
for now so um he has to move the bishop
and i have stuff stuff going here like
Bishop g3 I might have night f4 takes
Queen g2 king you 1 near that sets
possible Bishop have three well and
maybe even more check check hmm it's
dangerous it's definitely dangerous now
for white
okay I really don't know what is playing
now ah what is his move Knight f4 is
something and I'm threatening me five as
well okay yeah now I can definitely take
on junior here takes Queen e1 ruchi to
stuff yeah I'm staging a comeback here
and at c4 is hanging as well whoa and he
Oh can't check check check so what's the
deal check I'll take this bishop as well
white Wow coming back from a pretty bad
position down but I'm not sure he went
with his age for stuff here I don't know
I I don't think this is particularly
necessary and maybe it could have done
something simple and then just crushed
me okay so um there's a question by then
mrow it seems like a funny question but
this is not studying tactics for some
period of time decreases one tactical
skills despite the fact one studying
tactics generally
I don't understand the question I'm
sorry icse I see you ll see the point
yeah if you um if you don't study
tactics for a while and it's something
that is comparable to doing alright for
doing regular exercise that same
physical exercise I think it's like it's
easier to get muscles back if you had
them but don't doing something will
still kind of decrease your ability for
a while so I think having done something
and stop it and go back doing it it's
bad better than never doing anything so
you laid some groundwork but you still
will um lose some ability if you do
don't do stuff for a while ok I'm
playing the Banco which is currently
what I'm what I'm trying here I blitz
games and okay somehow I feel like I
don't know it too well but huh
okay 396 yeah I'm playing the bank oh I
tried that a bit in my recent blitz
games and it worked out pretty well a
recommendation for king and pawn endgame
books hmm I think what you're watching
need is you need some basic endgame book
which would be the 100 n games you must
know by Dara via and the end game menu
will buy the red ski those are the two
and chem books that you probably want I
usually say you don't need much more
okie dokie mr. Moreno is that good I
have a pretty nice pressure here for my
palm I'm not sure if the banker with
sound but this line with an early Queen
85 seems to be hard to kill off it's
currently in fashion okay so I need to
do something quickly here exploit his
weird coordination
yeah this is a difficult situation now
for what if he takes a look takes he
will almost certainly lose its end upon
f3 I can take there's a question I made
grind what type of knowledge abilities
of chess would be the last deteriorate
over time from activity I think as to
teaching understanding this is something
that is usually pretty stable kind of or
let's say it's something that is not so
much about daily practice it's something
that you have a quiet maybe by studying
or you have some natural talent yes
secrets of porn ending so this is also
one big book about king and porn endings
obviously by mula and lump reached i
think it is not sure about the second
guides definitely Carson Buddha the
German endgame expert um okay so what's
the deal here I wonder mmm do I take
here not sure about it maybe let's take
try to activate that rook
okay so what's what about this rook f4
interesting move he's got the potential
far away outside passer is the right
term I don't like that so much KS Assam
or asks how many rating point is
realistic to expect to gain on average
for one who takes chest seriously and
studies impossible to say it really is
impossible to say um I think it's
actually very much possible to and to
gain playing strength sir quite quite
quickly but it still takes a while and
it's nothing that will be for a thought
I was more expecting before but anyway
and see what happens so what is he doing
here King be sick so what's the point I
want to use my king to stop the porn
I think what was said here below 2000
gain in 100 to 200 points a year it's
doable um no I think this is not not
impossible not unrealistic okay so let's
check him ok so just goes for the for
the double attack here I can't see
okay let's keep this try to stay active
how do i get both paws rolling maybe
like this check poor ok so let's get my
pawns going here check
check
t-34 your phone check nah oh how cupid
um it's okay hey yeah black resins seen
ya was a stupid move I mean I'm
completely okay of course and just rook
c8 I didn't didn't just didn't see it
okay oh no no I accidentally pressed the
three minute game okay so let's make a
quick game there I didn't want a three
minute game and so the question was what
is indirect skis book that's not in the
day avea book to read his book is the
more comprehensive won the day of data
via book is some having all the
important basic endings while the the
droid ski book has also complicated
warning strategic ones and so on the
deer via book is great if you want to
give the foundation and the dread ski
book just has everything I mean like
everything er WT 64 says I did a
vacation my bluntness of the last week
weeks indicate that yes you're right
you're absolutely right I need a
vacation and they have a vacation coming
up I still have to yeah I have to hang
on a little bit now it's not Jamaica but
i'm still looking looking forward to it
i will have some vacation time in
germany coming up and then something in
slovenia like every year basically so
i'm very much looking forward to that
um okay what contributed the most to my
personal chess improvement difficult to
say I think the time when I improved the
most as a junior player I think it was
some analyzing my own games without help
of an engine this always was I think
very rewarding very interesting so this
is a three minute game I don't really
care that much I simply misclicked and
now I'm in this game yeah would you make
us probably interesting but indeed i'm
not a big fan of flying especially not
any longer distances
mp3 is good where's he going to a 3-yard
and it's in 2d six okay yeah maybe just
double let's double up we're going to
whoop CH here I don't have a clear
tactical way of doing things against
rook c8 at least I don't see it even
though the position looks good that's
the question what effective methods for
improving calculation if there is
something else and doing puzzles um no I
think there isn't much else I think you
have to just solve and solve positions
it's am what's what's getting it's a bit
the best reward for your time have to do
it constantly
I mean it makes sense to think about
calculation technique here like
candidate moves and stuff do you
calculate with the correct approach
things like that but once you have
established that you time when you do it
basically correctly you just have to do
it all over again you just can take this
what am I doing here Wow check check
okay very very weird check check now wow
check now we have to do those tactics
trainers they are really really
important and then good check
check focus should be eight check 20
seconds check for for the black layer
here check and probably wants to draw
and nope doesn't want to draw and okay
yeah this is good unfortunately check
check check check check check check
check check check check check blog for
all the dirty tricks and three minute
chess ok so I'm sorry it was I didn't
want to play through minute in the first
place so let's get a five minute game on
the road so yeah correspondence chess I
don't think I don't think it makes that
sense nowadays has all people use
computers it was a really cool thing
like 25 years ago I'm going to play one
over the board chess tournament
somewhere in Porto Rocha slovenia will
be very nice at the coast
there's a question if d three lines and
the Spanish makes sense yes definitely
it's a good good thing to do er double
duty says if I could choose a mentor to
help me to become a GM who would it be
yeah someone with with good and chem
knowledge I totally enjoyed working with
Alexia Malinsky for the commentary
because he really yeah showed me I mean
I know that my end game is not so great
and he really was fantastic in that so
someone like that would be pretty good
there's also a question here about my
channels content there wasn't something
like no tactics trainer for a while and
things like that this is true and I mean
I can maybe use this this show to
announce that I will make some changes
in my channel and I will definitely do
something else I will very likely go for
less blitz games and do other things
because I'm frankly speaking somewhat
some somewhat tired of the of the Blitz
routine I simply need to do some other
things it simply bores me to do the
blitz games every day and I think it
also bought the audience in a lot in the
long run certainly there are fans of
them of the blitz games i understand and
they're bound to scrap them permanently
but i need to change something in the
channel and simply cannot do it like
that forever it's simply it's simply
boring so i will do some other videos
i'm not quite sure how this would look
like the scheduling what when what
exactly but
I am will definitely post other content
simply because of being BAM I'm just
bought it with this daily blitz games ok
so here I'm trying to use the c6 square
maybe you can just play Queen to be 6
and is fine maybe Bishop c7 is that
something here like a shocker shocking
movement probably not and the thing is
he has got this if 5 thing if I've is
possibly coming hmm yeah defended that
well it's a bit lame but I don't I
didn't see anything else I Scotty 5
coming up it's really really it's really
nothing hmm strange so what you do here
black has just equalized very very
comfortably
yeah i will definitely try to i will
definitely try to do daily updates i
think daily update is something that
makes a lot of sense yeah this is really
a totally boring and lame position I can
play Roxy 394 may be here hmm but should
be five that might have been a mistake
um this one maybe yeah it's pretty bad
it's pretty bad yeah other
collaborations yeah this is also an
interesting idea play matches and stuff
but this is something okay can be done
but I want to also get something on the
road that I that I do on my own yeah
this is a really bad game on my god had
absolutely zilch even though we played a
somewhat questionable opening me not the
gruene felt and the roof it is ok but
details and a six is really strange so
what is he doing here trying to grab a
phone yeah for sure ok I need to make it
interesting even though this is probably
questionable g5
I think you can just take a for nothing
particularly wrong with that okay he
wants to prevent you for witches
possible this is probably not great but
I didn't want to stay passive so rook do
you one or something God can probably
even go see too hmm I check in and then
move the night bag I would check this
out here 495 g5 sh6 that could be an
idea no maybe maybe everybody is on
facebook really isn't facebook like a
thing of the past I thought what's
what's the newest thing snapchat I think
right this is what the kids are doing so
what about this do I have something here
I can check here check on edge aid check
here it's at least a million checks
check
and Jack may be something else check so
I gotta draw can I do something else hmm
yeah I wonder I mean if he if he
promotes i have a check made I could
actually like move the king it doesn't
make any sense this is the the question
time morning it's that too risky maybe
that's probably complete [ __ ] sorry
for the words I mean I cannot promote
this would would be checkmate like rook
takes Queen da checker it's very easy
thing but yeah oh ok they've also
cheapest trap ever unless I overlooked
something
huh
yeah it was a simple thing yeah I mean
facebook i think it's it's it is in some
way it's useful especially if you think
about let's say when i left my regular
job there were many people that I'd like
to stay in contact with of course you
can also do that with without the means
but I can contact them on facebook and
it's nice that this is possible okay so
what you do here maybe the hook over 2
m3 threatens made in to check
it was a very lucky win glug forfeits on
time yep very lucky win I didn't get a
French defensin somehow maybe i can get
about 2,400 again that would be cool icq
i think i CQ is inactive right I think
they switched it off yeah it was very
popular back in the day high risk to
remember that yeah let's get a new game
what I can also do once in a while is to
do Cuba thing gain started Rex xfer so
one French defence No so g3 is the move
yeah let's play natural-looking moves
maybe just develop stuff it's not clear
nope and he didn't didn't go for me oh
wow that's it's very exciting thought
you would try before a for stuff ok
anyway yeah m ir see IRC ok this
technique of all this technological base
of IRCs oh I think it's still somewhat
backbone of um um um the ICC I think at
least in some ways those commands they
resemble I RC IC remember ilc from the
very early
days of the internet yeah I went 45 to
make this night on the night on a three
years looking a little bit stupid
no I won't do a data stream for my
channel this is very unlikely that i
have the time for that I need something
that I can pre produce there's simply so
that the thing is I don't get um I don't
get I mean I cannot make like one hour
per day happen that can be that works
every day it just doesn't work because
of my merchants teaching I sometimes
have days where start new German time
and and to work in with small food
breaks until midnight and impossible to
get a streaming
it's a simple question how old I you I'm
42 years old okay one longer stream and
then make a week out of content with
that I never thought about that I think
I think I just want to make i have made
videos into this instructional content i
want to do those again basically and yes
i'm a professional chess teacher it's
mostly the teaching business i also
create content like this one live shows
things like that ok so what to do here
Bishop g5 is just around the corner it's
a bit of an annoyance maybe this one it
doesn't have a very good square for the
bishop
wow that's not very exciting okay yeah
what to do okay one if I go Bishop c7 he
probably would offer Queen trade now
it's a little bit better for black but
it's still very boring okay kunj before
I can go F 5 i'm sorry i can't go at
five have you ever cheated nope I mean
probably in some way happen not in
chairs
I think I probably cheated in computer
games and those kind of things where you
get when you cannot be killed any more
hot stuff like that but not a chance of
course Wow g4 whoa so is still need some
time to digest that so um he wants to go
rookie one that's pretty clear
hmm well I can prevent that by Bishop f4
my rookie one then g5 that would win
actually Queen you for okay let's just
prevent your key one for the time being
and then see what happens I mean with g4
yes completely killed his dark squares
okay so g5 right and that's it the Queen
cannot protect you one anymore it was I
thought rather obvious idea white
resigns yeah stranger that that girl
that went down pretty pretty quickly
game starting okay has ste off 85 91 so
um okay I mean I go 1c4 maybe this is
something to honor caution we also was a
great English opening player so he'll
stay off what are you going to do here
what is going to do is to play really
quickly
yeah my place through the queenside if
you ask me okay so night on before who
upon takes would have been interesting
and definitely hear why it should be a
bit better because of the B file yeah I
guess so
yeah the only thing that worries me a
little bit that near the night is
unprotected wants to go to see 5 and
this with this move okay I go there
maybe 96 to before this is idea possible
possible so what now
hmm I want to trade office his nights
there this should move but I don't know
where ok I'll go here not sure about it
if this is so helpful
takes their night be three unsure about
it two straight this one first okay so
grab some space probably go to a six
then to before yeah and so I the square
right or does he have some great idea
that no yeah the night coming to before
this is a bit of an annoyance I need to
see if i can trade down but won't be so
easy night only two in particular
hmm what to do this maybe h co age 50
wow I didn't think about that move ever
okay not saying it's bad just I didn't
didn't occur to me at all i'm doing is
Simon sometime you can always challenged
me in my eyes to see silence which is
happening on a monthly basis okay he
goes 'if I've I had a night 26
d 5 I don't know CMC doesn't know either
my ICC samo has 20 boards but you have
to join as a CEO of course so what's the
deal this one for Queen to be one maybe
can also take now huh Oh check this is
Jack made I mean have I had some kind of
idea when asked when I took lag reserved
okay so that was a win and it propelled
me about 2400 again 2412 so i think i'm
going for one more game and see if i can
get a french defence on and if not
that's it for the day i'm pretty happy
with my play even though i had a had two
very stupid endgame losses the thing is
that it's like it fell feels like 30
degrees in my office in temecula yeah
okay come on give me a game it's not
that much going on at the moment here
let's see i also want to do more cubed
sink but it's nothing super interesting
to kibbutz nope
I'm definitely not going to play line
from Casa miel I've got white again okay
then do another see form no of course we
don't have air conditioning in Germany
not very common this is a funny line
night takes before its best oh okay I'm
taking this if you give me the beep on
I'm taking it Wow
Wow so I totally wacky position I've got
the moves pawn structure ever I made us
all see pawns okay let's develop and ask
questions later
okay I don't mind him taking the stuff
the more points it takes the better my
dark squared bishop will become so let's
see after i go here no there's no law
against air conditioning in germany it's
just that we usually don't have this hot
summer and hot days and it is very
uncommon to be built built in directly
into into the house so this is the
reason I is taking everything like
absolutely everything ok so here we go
96 and Knight f6 taking only voice is
really cheeky the really cheeky decision
so what's shaking jackets let's start
with this I didn't even consider that
move that's a bad bad sign I thought
King h8 for some reason is mandatory
I'll see how silly is that oh my god
maybe this is something King takes Queen
here attacks the rook and Bishop g5 is
an idea that wasn't planned at all but
it is dangerous
if you move the rock I think a rookie in
one could be interesting threatening
Bishop g5 all rights it's dangerous
really dangerous
who that might be difficult to defend
maybe yam and no Rukia one young
threatening Bishop g5 mate like made
into or something tough age form
okay if a chick now Bishop age three is
very close I could go King edge to it
would be funny move
King h3 might have creature h5 this
could work if I do the check first then
the king is sex
can edge 2 319 h5 still works I promise
the left to do it night f5 I can take
age 7 this is probably still quite
interesting but Queen age 5 is the move
after that I don't now here I have
enough i have enough here after Queen
takes edge some pretty sure about it
where is he going with the rook bishop d
phi f is also part of this class b
sharifa bishop t5 Nexus actually pretty
interesting Wow 55 okay and after play
threatens Bishop g5 now and going back
and over 26 is this idea okay I can take
their take a five it's probably not
enough Jack so check here yeah King 70
he managed to escape he managed to
escape it's probably still not that easy
and blitz wow what he allows the
discovery just like that maybe you can
do that time morning check check no sir
I cannot take this sick so I can go here
and take the Queen and I have to check
on be one as well check
what a bizarre game um okay check check
who could be five Janet's do this first
probably this is full of mistakes but
it's it's very very weird and
interesting ok I've to is hanging yeah
so better better book with chicks check
em ever to is still hanging check oh I
didn't see the chicken check I hope rich
it's the wind summer and check oh don't
have time check oh just take it black
wow I've got one second left oh oh my
goodness yeah my mom has a question my
head your head is so right it's about
the lighting it's not like I've got 500
blood pressure or something ETA list
kibbutz's smile yeah yeah what a mess
okay i hope you enjoyed this final game
it was a complete chaos and probably not
particularly correct but yeah anyway i
think it was entertaining to watch i
hope you enjoyed the show I'll be back
um next week the same time at the same
place ok bye bye guys have a good week
you